next month he's running a 100K through
the woods of British Columbia
and he's hoping that um he grew up in
New York City he's hoping as a city boy
he doesn't get mauled by a bear
please welcome Dan
all right so I'm here to talk to you
about moving to Cordo from our markdown
or python Jupiter notebooks
um so hello everyone but before we get
started uh I would first like to
acknowledge that we are currently on the
unsuceded land of the Muncie and the
Lenape people
and I'm Daniel I'm currently a
postdoctoral research and teaching
fellow at the University of British
Columbia up in Vancouver
I'm from New York City but I moved up
there uh over a year ago and I'm
currently a data science educator at
posit I got all of my teaching
background from the carpentries and I
also authored a book about pandas in
Python
but this talk is about literate
programming which is the ability for you
to write code and write regular prose
text and interweave it together in a
single document or report it also allows
you to write slide decks like we've
learned from emu Emil earlier today and
also this talk is also written in quarto
which is also another form of literate
programming that I'm going to be talking
to you about today
so literary programming who would use it
why would you want to use it so as a
data scientist you may or may not have
learned or used our markdown or Jupiter
notebooks and for people like us it's
really good for doing analysis or
reports and documentation if you're also
an academic you can write your papers in
it I sort of have this project that
maybe I'll try to translate my
dissertation into quarto and just see
how well the tool works that's sort of
what I want to try it out for but even
as a technical writer you can use it for
not just quarto but just literate
program in general you can use it to
write blogs or websites or presentations
or books and all of that stuff so that
whole realm of content is called
literate programming
as our users we're probably have heard
or used a tool called our markdown it's
been around for many many years
and
I'll give you a if you don't know about
our markdown then this is sort of the
main component of an R markdown document
where you have three backticks a set of
curly braces the letter R and then in
here in your regular document you get
the right regular R code as if it was in
your console or in a script or right in
our studio
and this gives you the ability
to take that R code and write regular
prose text with it so I can have a
regular markdown header that says like
here's a section about loading data here
are some regular text about what the
data set is and here's the code to load
the data up at the top I have some
metadata information about what the
title would be what type of output so
right now I'm picking an HTML output you
can set it to PDFs or other forms of
output as well and then there's also
some things that you just have to do or
load but you don't really want to be
part of the report so you have the
ability to still run code but sort of
turn off the output so no one really
sees it in your final report so that's
the main part of in our markdown
document
and what we can do is we can take that
regular R code or that document
that you just saw and you can run a
command right in your command line
called rscript and you can run this
function called render from the markdown
Library
and what it will do is then generate the
format that you asked for so in previous
example you saw I asked for an HTML
output running this code will give me a
HTML file of that code
I talk a lot about project formats and
project templates so what I also like to
do is specify like hey when you generate
this HTML output please put it in the
output folder so I don't end up with the
folder with 50 files all in one go
and you end up with a file that looks
like this during that output so here's
the longer form of that type of analysis
I'm loading data filtering data saving
doing some tightening stuff plotting and
then fitting a model and you get like a
nice little report
in here and so I can have code see it's
output and write about it all in one go
but this talk is about quarto so you can
think of quarto as like the next
iteration of our markdown our markdown's
not really going anywhere but there was
a lot of things learned during the
development of our markdown and so Court
of sort of encompasses all of the things
that were learned and sort of tries to
make it better so it's still a plain
text Source document so you can open it
in any type of uh
program that you that can read plain
text files it still does literate
programming Cordo natively just has
multi-language support so you can have
an R document a python document or an r
and python document it also out of the
box supports Julia and observable for
JavaScript
and you can take a quarter document very
similar to our markdown and generate
multiple outputs so PDFs HTML files
anything else that I can't think of
because I don't really use and that's
all because it's built on top of pandok
so you can to write regular markdown and
then they can generate out into
something a little bit prettier
and the nice thing about it about
quarter at least for my end and maybe a
lot of people here at this conference is
that it's just more familiar because
it's coming from the r markdown world so
hopefully you don't have to do that much
more work to get using Cordo if you are
already using our markdown
so
a lot of the um we can actually
use quarto to render the same exact our
markdown file
and
we'll get a nice little out piece of
output that looks like this so it's
really similar the formatting is a
little bit different you'll see at the
bottom I added the ability to just put
in a table of contents and so you get a
nice little table of contents on the
side instead of at the top so as I
scroll it's kind of always there with us
so that's like one of the nicer things
that comes out of coral out of the box
compared to something like on lockdown
but there's a couple of differences if
we actually want to create a quarto
document like a DOT qmd instead of Dot
rmd
in the yaml header really the only thing
we need to change is instead of output
HTML document it's now format HTML and a
lot of the other bits and pieces there
are some overlaps there are some new
things some things get taken out Etc et
cetera
the other thing
about quarto and our markdown documents
um
I forgot the exact version of our
markdown but you can now take all of
those command line chunk options and
actually put them in line using this
Hash Pipe and then you can now have all
of those options as a comment in your
code and that's really nice because if
you start doing things like doing figure
captions or alt text the problem in the
previous way was everything actually had
to be in that first line and things just
ran off the screen and it gets really
hard especially if you're using some
Version Control System
so this sort of allows us to separate
things out and make things that part
just a little bit nicer to work with
but that's generally the only sets of
changes that we need to make
and then from there instead of telling
quarto render to render the rmd document
we can just say hey I just created this
qmd document can you go and output that
as well and
the only sort of tricky thing about if
you're just working with qmd files and
you want to sort of have the output go
into a different directory you sort of
have I do this thing where you turn the
whole thing into like a quarto project
and then the output directory and the
output file formats you can sort of use
but if it's just a regular quarter
document and you don't care about
exactly what the file name and the file
output is you can just use plain old
quarto render or sort of do this I do
this as a little hack where you just
turn the whole project into a quarto
project
so that's sort of like the little weird
thing with using quarter documents only
if you're trying to render individual
quarter documents it doesn't apply for
like websites or slides and stuff like
that that use the quarter yaml file and
it just needs to exist for this whole
process to work so you don't have to put
anything in that yaml file it just sees
the file and then it's like oh it's a
project I know what to do now but if you
want to read more about like this sort
of issue or any developments like here's
two links about
um the discussion and then there's this
other way where you can have a
pre-render script or post render script
that if you really want to move stuff
around you can sort of put that in your
workflow as well
um and that's all around this concept
around project templates that I talk a
lot about so in like DCR and nyr I've
given two talks about project templates
I've taught a course with Tiffany
Timbers at UBC it's DSi 310 and it's
around like reproducible workflows for
data science and like project templates
are also like another thing about it so
I really care about project templates
I'm the person if I'm in your group
project like I just deal with the file
like structure of it and then I just
make that that's like one of my things
that I get really annoyed if it's not um
set up properly so I usually end up
handling that
okay so Jupiter
um if you've used Jupiter notebooks
there's these two sort of talks uh one
that says I don't like notebooks and
that's store sort of stirred the the
boat a little bit
um and then there was like a follow-up
discussion called I'd like notebooks and
you can um you'll have access to the
slides and you can actually watch those
talks about like the pros and cons of
of working with actual Jupiter notebook
files but I think like both of the
speakers there like they do have a point
like there are pros and cons with any
tool that you use but here's like my
list of what I've what I agree with and
what I don't agree with or just my
workings with Jupiter notebooks is that
it's really good for technical writing
it does the whole literate program thing
almost like too much uh because there's
no easy way to hide certain bits of the
output you just see everything like all
the time which is for better for worse
if you really want transparency you have
that option but on the downside like at
the end of the day like if you try to
double click the file if you can even
double click the file it's really just
this giant Json file and that just makes
Version Control kind of like messy but
on the plus side if you upload a Jupiter
notebook to like GitHub it automatically
renders so that's like a really nice
thing as well quarto documents and our
markdown documents if you upload them to
GitHub it just gets rendered as like
just the plain text file so Jupiter
notebooks it's really nice like after a
workshop and I'm teaching out of Jupiter
it's just like here's all my stuff and I
don't have really have to think about
making things prettier
um it's just this is exactly what
happened in the workshop
um for data science the thing with
Jupiter notebooks is I sort of treat it
more like an output format than a source
document or at least that's how most
people use it because all of the output
and figures are all in the same document
so again if you start using Version
Control you just you sort of end up in
the scenario where like you're now
version controlling like output of code
and not just like the raw Source part of
the code so again it's really nice for a
workshop
you sort of run into issues like or
like humps speed bumps as you're working
in like Version Control
but at UBC we use this a lot or jupyter
notebooks a lot in teaching there's this
tool called mbgrader and it auto helps
automate a lot of our student
assignments and stuff like that so there
is a lot of tools and there's an
ecosystem around Jupiter notebook so
that's always really great especially if
you're a teacher
but again like I've talked about Jupiter
notebooks being Json like here's just
like the first two or three bits of the
actual Json so you like you see some of
the code bits and like here's like the
markdown of the thing and then like I
tell it to like give me the first five
lines of the data set so like here's the
HTML view here's the actual like plain
text View and then this is the actual
code right so like you can see like
it's really easy to sort of like
accidentally delete a delete a comma
especially if you're trying to deal with
merge conflicts of some sort
um and then like the entire notebook
doesn't even load so like there's like a
really high chance of like just not
looking at it in a dedicated notebook
application you're going to screw
something up
so there are tools uh vs code on the
left and Jupiter lab on the right
um there are now like tools that at
least with vs code I can at least double
click the thing and just view it
um but Jupiter lab you always have to
like make sure that Python's installed
and running all the tools are are there
and then you have to be able to load it
up and then hopefully everything loads
but at least there's at least with vs
code you have a chance to like just look
at the output without having to worry
about like if you have everything
installed properly
but that's sort of the downside because
it's not really a plain text format is
like I still really need a dedicated
tool to sort of just browse and look at
this look at a notebook compared to like
a qmd file that's a markdown file really
with some special
um bits of syntax in it but
um this is sort of just what evolved in
the python ecosystem and that's why it's
super popular
and Jupiter does do R um you need the IR
kernel that you can install and then all
of a sudden you get this nice little r
notebook so for those of you who are you
know in a python shop but you're but you
like know R you can actually get this
stuff installed and sort of like
integrate yourself into a python team if
you want and still have a
a thing that looks like a python
notebook until they open it and it's
like what is going on here but
um but it is kind of nice and we do this
at UBC as well when we teach our intro
data science course we teach it in R but
using Jupiter notebooks
and so
if you were to programmatically in the
command line want to render a
python notebook you can use jupyter
convert and you can convert whether or
not it's a python notebook or an R
notebook and it'll give you like the
HTML format because that's what I ask
for
and like I said like one of the things
is I personally try to keep the jupyter
notebook as a source document so one of
the things I like to do is when I'm in
my make file or right before I'm going
to check my code in there's this option
now to pass in clear output and so you
don't have to have the notebook open to
sort of like kernel reset kernel delete
output you can do this in the command
line which sort of gives you a lot more
flexibility how you call this and this
way at least if you're in a notebook
flow
the inversion control it's still just
the source code so if you're really um
like I want to use notebooks all the
time this is sort of how you can reduce
the amount of friction especially if
you're working with Version Control
and then if you really want the rendered
output you can turn the output to an
actual notebook file so you actually do
have source and rendered version
um
as part of your analysis or your project
but quarto again can also work with
notebooks as well so your barrier and
Truth to using quarto is really as
simple as like calling quarto render and
then just passing in the jupyter
notebook file it doesn't by default
execute the code from top to bottom it
just says like whatever is rendered in
here I'm going to dump it out so if you
really wanted to run the code from top
to bottom like kernel run all you pass
in this dash dash execute and it will
actually go and run the code out for you
and you end up with
the Cordo version of a Jupiter notebook
looks something like this and then the
regular version of the Jupiter notebook
looks like this so really it's the same
amount of things and you can see like
here's actual python code looks has like
the chordal template around it as well
oh yeah and so this is just the code
bits for like all of the extra stuff
that I usually put in so
converted to an X HTML execute the code
from top to bottom add in a table of
contents put it in a special location
really in like some type of output
folder and then I have it as a name
this is the actual name of the HTML file
that's what you ended up seeing in that
particular example
all right so the other thing let's say
for example you already have your
notebook and everything's already
rendered and you don't really want to
change it because
everything's already built in that
pipeline but you want to start like a
new report and that report needs bits
and pieces from that Jupiter notebook so
what you can actually do is actually
reference a Jupiter notebook add in some
metadata comments and then it can find
those bits in the Jupiter notebook and
put it into your quarter document so you
don't really have to change any of the
code bits if you already have a jupyter
notebook pipeline but if you're ready
for like oh I need to write like another
report and I'm going to try this new
tool called quarto that's another way
you can sort of dabble with using quarto
so I have all of these example files if
you look at the repository at the bottom
like all the example files are there
there's a make file so you can actually
see all the commands that get run as
well but so first let's render a
notebook just so that all of the output
is somewhere and then all you need to do
is in the cell of a jupyter notebook use
regular quarter
um
comments and you can add bits and pieces
of
quarto like metadata stuff into a
Jupiter notebook cell and then in your
quarto document you use a short code you
say embed and then the actual name of
the Jupiter notebook and then literally
like whatever the label that you have in
that cell so right here label fig hist
that's all you need to put into your
quarter document and then you render the
quarto document just like normal
and you end up with
a document like this so this is a quarto
document and all I ended up doing was
putting in that shortcode and this is
pulling actually that image straight
from the Jupiter notebook and just
inserting it into my chordo document and
at the bottom you'll see that like
there's even a reference to the jupyter
notebook so it does like cross reference
back to like this is where the original
thing came from and if you want you can
download that notebook as well so it's a
really nice way of like hey I just want
to start a report I already have
something working and I don't really
want to change that pipeline too much
this is a nice little way to like oh use
quarto use it to build your websites or
your slide decks or something and just
use bits and pieces from your notebook
world
last thing I want to talk about is
converting so there's another tool
called jupy text and you can use a tool
you can use this particular tool to
rewrite your rmd document to a quarto
document or a jupyter notebook file to a
quarter document you can use this tool
called jupy text to handle that for you
so you just end up with your regular qmd
file that's been translated over
and then quarter convert is also another
tool that you can use where you can say
like hey here's my Jupiter notebook file
turn this notebook file into a qmd file
and it will do its best to translate
everything over it does a pretty good
job but you might still have to go do
some minor tweaks of things but that's
about it but it's a really good way to
get started if you already have a
notebook and you just want to I just
want to try Cordo let me just convert
everything and start from there this is
a really good way of dealing with that
last is publication so you can actually
publish your files using quarto publish
so for example I can this talk is
actually published on quarto Pub so if I
were you you can go to coropub.com make
an account
just claim your username right now and
then you can sort of publish your stuff
onto Port Coral plugs right so thank you
and then here's all the resources for
everything that you need
foreign